bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est à le
récap archos et s on va aller voir la
french cancan voir ce que la france a de
mieux au niveau technologique
je pense qu'on va trouver des pépites
ans va trouver des petites perles on va
aller voir ça tout de suite donné
aujourd'hui on est avec maxime de
business france la french est qu on est
aux crs alors est ce qu'on peut faire un
petit peu un tour d'horizon savoir
comment s'est passé le cs pour la french
state un bon cru 2010 8 ou pas du tout
un énorme cru déjà il y avait sur plus
de 300 cela fait française sur le récap
art c'est juste la zone où il ya des et
les petites start-up innovante va donc
c'est la deuxième délégation n'est juste
les américains alors que jouer à
domicile mais j'ai pas mal
on a eu des belles budget
mahjoubi traitèrent d'état au numérique
beaucoup de présidents présidence de
région
les pécresse qui était
be nice
et à côté de ça pour parler un peu plus
business
et quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
trop distributeurs legros retailer et
c'est ce que viennent chercher un petit
peu les start up
elles ont un produit à vendre donc elles
veulent le mettre dans tous les magasins
du monde
et je peux pas encore dévoiler non mais
y en a qui ont
du très belle discussion ouais oui
vraiment des start up qui ont été
présents cette année sur deux françaises
qui vont vraiment pouvoir froide ça
vraiment être un levier
on va rencontrer avoir les bons contacts
et faire du business international
entièrement parce que en fait à deux
choses souvent que les pertes viennent
chercher c'est soit vendre le produit
et c'est le cas pour les personnes qui
étaient prêts à aller sur le marché
georget vos produits j'ai beau packaging
allez on va on va attaquer tout le monde
entier minimum et après tu les toutes
les start up qui avaient envie de se
faire connaître un petit peu et du
combattant vie que de passer devant la
presse la grèce même international et
forcément quand tu as un innovation
droit best of innovations lancées qui
fait un radiateur à urbès nos fils de ma
chaîne wii ou les journalistes qui sont
du mémoire petit peu dit je sais j'ai
déjà vu des vidéos avec ben helli
dès qu'ils le prennent par terre il ya
un amas il faut le film et damas deux
personnes qui qui viennent se mettre à
genoux à côté de lui font le plus parler
avec lui il a même eu d'ailleurs stevie
wonder volage et les voir hier ya stevie
wonder qui est venu échanger avec avec
buddy rota
mais mustier qui l'onil oui ouais un
trait qui donnent ils étaient sur leur
est capable c'est génial donc cru énorme
alors du coup deuxième délégation mais
il y a j'ai vu des graphiques
je vois que les états unis sont
effectivement pas bien placé la france
était derrière et les autres n'y a pas
grand chose
d'accord il n'y a pas grand chose après
tout ça c'est souvent des discussions
qui sont relativement cette politique
est-ce que l'état envie d'aider les
startup hardware ses ex pendre à
l'international c'est pas si évident
nous ça nous paraît normal puisqu'on
connaît la piste est qu on connaît les
volontés de monsieur emmanuel macron
on connaît l'activité de
mahjoubi c'est pas le cas dans tous les
pays pour vous faut bien qu'on se rend
compte c'est qu'on a une vraie chance et
de supporter en tout cas sur ce domaine
là
en plein de domaines pour les start up
mais là on est sur un salon aliotti
harware oui on a on est aidé et après il
ya quand même un effet sur yon honnête
c'est que le cs attire beaucoup les
français
lui ce qui peut attirer des anglais ou
des italiens c'est à dire comment
commence à arriver un petit format semé
lerrick à part au cms de las vegas
est un salon qui je ne sais pas pourquoi
et très envié par les stars prépare bois
d'ailleurs tu t'es
forcément rendu compte qu'on parle
beaucoup français dans les allées je me
sens je me sens plus en france ici que
dans les autres rôles ou là bas j'ai
complètement largués ici c'est vraiment
bien
bref tout ce que tu vas autre chose à
rajouter un message à passer le message
à passer c'est
de continuer à suivre monsieur gautier
temps c est de revenir l'année prochaine
évidemment
nous forcément à la fin on va commencer
à préparer l'année 2019 et je pense que
on va travailler davantage encore sur la
qualité des start up et
on verra de toutes les couleurs j'ai un
bien bon merci beaucoup maxime avec
plaisir merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
je vous invite bien évidemment à me
laisser vos commentaires on me dira ce
que vous pensez de tout cet
environnement technologique français la
high-tech française le meilleur de la
france qui est présent ici à l'oreca
parc à las vegas au cs vous mettez tous
vos commentaires toutes vos suggestions
toutes vos questions qu'on peut tout
partager vous évite bien évidemment
amené à 10 pouces à vous abonner
comme d'habitude et on reste connectés
parce qu'on va parler toujours plus de
start up française innovante d'un
submersible la toile